chaos und zerstörung auf den straßen von
belfast verursacht von zumeist
protestantischen jugendlichen seit
wochen schaukeln sich die aggressionen
immer mehr hoch ausgelöst durch ein
gefühl der ohnmacht isoliert durch die
pandemie benachteiligt gegenüber
katholischen republikanern gegängelt von
der polizei und vergessen von der
politik so ihr tenor der aus london
entsandt hat irland minister bietet
keinerlei trost im gegenteil die einzige
art dieses problem zu lösen ist
innerhalb eines diplomatischen
demokratischen politischen prozesses es
gibt keine rechtfertigung dafür mit
gewalt zu reagieren und das hilft
niemandem weiter egal wie groß die
sorgen für die realistische seite die
nach dem break cit mehr denn je eine
schleichende trennung vom mutterland
befürchtet stehen die schuldigen fest
sie drohen mit weiterer gewalt solange
das zwischen der eu und london
ausgehandelte nordirland protokoll nicht
annulliert wird
was wir hier sehen passiert wegen der
nordirischen polizei und wie sie
versucht ihre publica zu befrieden und
wegen der beerdigung des kämpfers bobby
story letzten sommer auf der keine
masken getragen und es ist auch die
schuld von boris johnson der die grenze
in die irische see verlegt obwohl er
versprochen hatte dass das niemals
passiert hatte dieser kilometer lange
peace wohl in west belfast trend ein
protestantisches von einem katholischen
arbeiterviertel zur sicherheit ihrer
anwohner doch sozialarbeitern die komik
uni zufolge fliehen immer mehr
realistische familien in kurdistan
tische vor ort wegen interner banden
gewalt und drogenkriminalität
zurück bleiben frustrierte
arbeiterkinder die gegenwärtigen unruhen
sind nicht zur konfessionsgebundenen wie
die leute glauben es ist vielmehr so
dass die vielen einschränkungen durch ko
witt 19
die grundrechte und freiheiten der
menschen stark beschnitten
es gibt viele junge leute hier die
normalerweise zugang zu sozialen
einrichtungen erziehungsprogramme oder
jugendarbeit haben und jetzt davon
abgeschnitten
sie fühlen sich isoliert es muss also
nur irgend etwas kleines passieren und
sofort kann alles explodieren
ein weiteres problem ex-mitglieder
radikaler realistischer splittergruppen
die sich längst enttäuscht von ihrem
politischen führern abgewandt und
mafiaähnliche strukturen gebildet haben
wie man vernachlässigte jugendliche
verführt ist ihnen von kindesbeinen an
vertraut
vielen von den jungen leuten hier
mangelt es
ich würde nicht unbedingt sagen an
bildung aber sie haben keine vorbilder
sie wissen nicht was drüben auf der
anderen seite der tramlinie passiert und
was dort für menschen
es gibt viele denen daran liegt
spannungen unter den jugendlichen
hervorzubringen die eigentlich viel mehr
miteinander verbindet als sie es
aber wenn man hinter zwölf meter hohen
mauern lebt entsteht eine atmosphäre des
misstrauens das sage ich als jemand der
hier aufgewachsen
[Musik]
während die katholischen viertel entlang
der pis wohlauf leben verelenden die
viertel der loyalisten immer mehr
sozialprogramme die oft von der eu
finanziert wurden fallen weg zurück
bleiben haltlose jugendliche die
ablenkung bei alkohol drogen und gewalt
suchen ihre stimmen hat die nordirische
künstlerin und aktivistin rita duffy in
wort und bild eingefangen in der schule
sieht sich nur um und uhr nichts ich bin
einfach nicht dafür gemacht
ich habe mich an alles gedrückt denn ich
wusste ich komme damit durch aber jetzt
mit 16 müsste ich eigentlich um eine
mittlere reife machen
ich wünschte meine mutter gar ein
bisschen strenger mit mir gewesen
die britische journalistin kate wurde da
berichtet seit 30 jahren über den
nordirland-konflikt die zukunftsängste
der loyalisten sind für sie real
langfristig deutet vieles darauf hin
dass irland sich wiedervereinigt auch
weil die eigene politische führung keine
alternativen für die katholische seite
aufzeigt mit fatalen folgen für die
junge generation hinter den aktuellen
gründen für die jetzigen unruhen stecke
etwas viel grundlegenderes nämlich die
tiefe spaltung der nordirischen
gesellschaft die immer noch nicht
überwunden ist und solange dies nicht
geschieht wird es immer wieder zu gewalt
kommen die herausforderung für die
politiker besteht also darin sie zu
verhindern
denn gerade die jungen menschen
zerstören durch ihre teilnahme an diesen
aufständen ihre eigene zukunft in dem
sie sich vor strafen einhandelt
kaum einer der jungen nordiren egal auf
welcher seite wünscht sich die zeit vor
dem karfreitagsabkommen zurück sie gehen
auf ein irisches gymnasium und wohne
hier gleich um die ecke
diese krawalle müssen aufhören gerade
kommen wir endlich aus dem block darm
und dann gibt es hier draußen mord und
totschlag und man kann schon wieder
nicht raus ich heiße mal grimm und komme
aus nord belfast mein leben ist zur zeit
sehr hart die aufstände machen mir angst
denn ich bin irgendwann sieht nicht in
dem schlechten alten zeiten groß
geworden ich will nicht wieder dorthin
wenn ich älter bin vielleicht kinder
haben werde möchte ich nicht dass sie an
so einem ort groß die zukunft
nordirlands bleibt eng mit seiner
vergangenheit verbunden
die politiker in london storm und aber
auch in brüssel haben es in der hand ob
die jungen nordiren den konflikt weiter
tragen oder ihn eines tages selbst
friedlich beilegen können